Two, three, four.
Oh, wait.
We almost started
without our special guest!
Helpsters!
- Shaggy!
Helpsters, we start looping
our sounds when Shaggy tells us
and then stop
when he stops singing.
Sound good?
- Yeah, it does.
Well, I think I'm going to start
with Heart.
[HEART VOCALIZES]
Scatter!
[SCATTER VOCALIZES]
Mister Primm!
[MISTER PRIMM VOCALIZES]
I've got to get you in here,
Cody.
[CODY VOCALIZES]
[ALL VOCALIZING]
♪ I'm here to say I like
sidewalks under my feet. ♪
♪ Over the side, a little higher
than the streets. ♪
♪ When I walk,
I prefer a safe location, ♪
♪ so I'm gonna get my feet
some elevation ♪
♪ with sidewalks. ♪
♪ Hey, now everybody walk
on the side, ♪
♪ bounce on the side, ♪
♪ dance on the side, ♪
♪ eat a snow cone on the side. ♪
♪ Sidewalks. ♪
♪ I'm here to say
I like sidewalks. ♪
♪ Oh, sidewalks. ♪
[VOCALIZING STOPS]
Shaggy!
- Scatter!
Hey, thanks for making
music with us today.
Thank you, my brother.
Big up yourself.
Yeah!
♪ Helpsters! ♪
♪